so at this point in the game you've  probably seen multiple ads on the vault  conferences on facebook on instagram on  youtube on linkedin all over the place  but you haven't yet made a decision for  yourself you talk to your spouse maybe  you talk to your business partner or  your peers saying hey let's go to this  thing together here's all i will tell  you if there's ever been a year  where you want to invest into yourself  to attend the conference to be around a  community to be around others that are  going through these uncertain times like  today this is the time to attend this  event so if you've not yet registered  make the decision click on the link  above or below get your tickets for you  your spouse your business partners and  i'll see you in miami first week of  september bye